folks folks folks the moment I see
bumblebee and/or Aquaman I will
certainly get on those reviews for
bumblebee and/or Aquaman for now mortal
engines so mortal engines is a movie
based on a book not directed by Peter
Jackson clarify that because the
marketing material had Peter Jackson's
name front and center stuff I saw anyway
Peter Jackson had a hand in writing it
but you know names marketability
what is this takes place about a
thousand years in the future we have
liked ourselves out a humanity that
survived rebuilt that civilization to be
in cities that are on wheels
that's right cities move around I
haven't seen mobile cities since I saw
mobile schools in Final Fantasy 8 or
Final Fantasy 6 Castle did that it went
underground it's a little different what
is I see potential in the technology in
cinema maybe I'll see a Final Fantasy 6
movie one day maybe it won't suck maybe
because maybe they'll make it into a
serious like they probably should have
this movie right what I liked about the
movie is the imagination like the world
is interesting and yeah that's me pretty
much saying visuals cool the visuals
were pretty cool suspending disbelief
that it's all completely illogical and
you see in this movie why it's illogical
couples of cities like you mean if we
take those out that'll come crashing
down
alright we're dead but it just makes for
interesting worlds and the first act of
this movie maybe the first half of the
first act of this movie it was actually
quite exciting there was a chase
sequence with two cities there was a
chase sequence among people in a city
while they're running through the city
you see how it operates you just kind of
thought of Columbia but not in the air
but really the moment the youth fall off
the city the moment they go over the
rail this movie falls off the rails eye
falls off the rails I mean kind of
grinds to a halt it's not getting messy
so that's getting sloppy too many plot
lines are thrown at you this is one of
the tough things about adapting a book
to a movie there's so much that happens
in a book you got to cut things out I'm
sure they did cut things out for this
ever read the books I don't know for
sure
they just didn't cut enough like I
forgot for so long in this movie that
this girl's sole focus is to kill Hugo
Weaving because he killed her mother
because I didn't care I didn't care
about that plotline that's so important
to the plot I didn't care about the
Roman are they forming a romance there
is a romance right there still making
young adult novels is that fad still a
thing the foreshadowings way too obvious
to at a point you're like let me guess
that's coming at the end anytime a movie
has a couple different groups in a
couple different locations doing their
own campaign you have to make it work
this movie does not do that most of the
time you're with the why a Roman
novel people and it bounces back to
London you're like oh yeah them I forgot
about them and that's never good the
coolest thing in this movie was a side
plot that really didn't mix with the
main plot at all it has to do with this
robot zombie he was cool I was most
interested in him he was awesome he was
the best part of the movie he was like
if Tin Man and The Terminator had a kid
there's the thing I will remember about
this movie so you probably should have
made a movie about that and again I'm
sure the book isn't based on that so how
could that maybe you should have
integrated that plot into this movie
better and left out that scene when
they're in that little caterpillar thing
not really a caterpillar is a vehicle
that looks like a caterpillar cut a lot
of that out and concentrate on the Robo
zombie if for nothing else this movie
shows me that this should have been a
series I get that this would have been
difficult to adapt into a series because
how do you muster up the budget to show
that you really can't not for a serious
I don't know I'm saying is adapting
something like this to a movie is just
gonna cost someone money watch it makes
this budget back I'm gonna look like an
[ __ ] guys in the end mortal engines
wasn't as bad as I thought it was gonna
be it was not good enough for me to say
yeah you should watch it it's just it's
forgettable when I walk out of a movie
I'm like what's the rewatch ability
there and it's not it's not rewatchable
it should've been about a half an hour
shorter is filled with illogic not
illogic in terms of like cities can't be
mobile not like that I'm saying in the
end you have the tech head who should go
do the thing to stop the super death
machine and they send the girl she does
[ __ ] about tech he should have
definitely been the one to go do the job
or make her the tech head then you can
send her the coolest thing about this
movie is that it's a really imaginative
interesting world biggest bummer is they
didn't take that interesting imaginative
world and put it in a movie that works
I've had an interesting concept isn't
enough you have to make the movie flow I
expected nothing from this movie I for
the first act I was really rooting for
it didn't pay off as well as I would
have liked and I'll say it probably be
better if you were drunk
yeah no it's farting all right so mortal
engines have you seen it what did you
think about it alright when you don't
watch this was another one in Super
Smash Brothers ultimate who is your main
whoever it is comment below let me know
couldn't think of anything else and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]